I like I like things a little weird you
know if you follow me you know I like we
had some weird [__] happen in Naples a
couple weeks back first of all I don't
know if you've ever been to Naples
Florida but I want to tell you a couple
things about Naples Florida if we went
to Naples Florida all of us we would all
be the youngest people in Naples
Florida every person in here would be
the youngest [__] person in Naples
Florida okay let me tell you be that
place is so old okay when I if you've
ever flown into Naples
it's all you get on a plane into Naples
it's old people and I'm I'm
superstitious man when I fly I'm always
like is I'm always looking for a sign
like is this the plane that I shouldn't
get
on and there's so many old people on
those planes you get on you're like is
this one going straight to heaven
or why are there 50 [__] wheelchairs
on the ramp out
there
is an old [__] place right and by the
way at the place where I play there it's
like also known for its food so people
go there to eat and every year there's
at least one old dude that doesn't know
he's at a comedy show
and he's just got his back to me eating
the whole [__]
show never [__] turns it's
amazing but this year okay
and so at that place because it's also
the place where they eat the the the
seating is banquet style so long thin
tables and so people sit basically like
you man so there's no chairs like this
they're all like back to back they're
sitting like uh you know moped style you
[Laughter]
know and so they're sitting there and
there's a woman here and a man here and
H every time time I would tell a joke
and people would laugh she would
laugh and then she would turn to the guy
behind her and I could just see her
going
good turn back but she would only do it
when there was laughter and then she
would turn and just give him a
little and I could see the blood just
slowly draining out of this dude's face
and then he just screams you're not
going to [__] talk to me like
that now I'm going to tell you something
the only real difference between what
she was saying to him and what he was
saying to her is that she said her
things during the loud
Parts he said his thing during the
[__] dead quiet part yeah yeah yeah
so everybody was like oh what and I look
over at him I go hey man I was like Hey
see you guys
arguing I'm sorry you're probably going
to have to leave and she turns to him
and she goes did you hear what he just
said to
you he told you to shut the [__]
up and I was like no I did not say
that that didn't come out of my mouth
none of those [__] words did I'll
tell you that right
now and um the guy was getting a little
feisty and so the B comes over now by
the way
balancer it looks just like a taller
meate I was like he didn't ask for
ketchup dude bring the muscle you
know the guy standing here in front of
me and the bounce was like I need you to
relax and then the dude stands up now
this the first time we see him he stands
up he's got his arm in a
sling right Florida you
know and um this get his arm sling and
he stands up and the bouncer goes
through him why'd you stand up and the
guy points at me and he goes I'm gonna
kick his
ass the bouncer goes if you want to get
to him you got to go through
me and I was like Bo
okay nobody's ever fought for my honor
before that was
amazing I was like dude you're getting a
hand job for sure tonight
ladies I get it that felt awesome you
know and so the the bouncer was like
though dude he was like dude but sit
back down you know I don't want to and
the [__] guy in the sling pulls out a
knife
[Music]
Flor and dude by the way and then the
bouncer did something that I've never
seen I've heard of people doing but I've
never seen it I've seen it like in old
movies and old TV shows but I've never
seen it like out in the wild before you
know yo the bouncer [__] karate
chopped
him I was like what the [__] if he had
given him a h I'd have been like
[__] you've never seen a karate chop in
your [__] life
he he kartic chopped him in the wrist
right the flew out of the guy's hand I
think the guy went I think he went
something the knife like [__] bing
bing bing
right and so the the guys the bouncers
and stuff they jump on this guy and they
pull his arm up both of them over head
and you could see there was still
stitches and [__] where he had a surgery
yeah dude he screaming you could see the
stitches because I forgot to to mention
sleeveless shirt naturally
uh that's what you were picturing I
didn't need to really add it in but that
is and the guy's screaming he's like by
my arm my arm he's like you want to be
cool yeah I'm G be cool they dropped his
arms he was not
cool so they pull his arms back over and
they grab his [__] feet and he's
kicking and [__] they and they bring him
outside and they hit his uh head on the
door jam twice uh
I said to the guy go head on the door
jam honey it was an accident I was like
not the second time it
was so they get him outside and his arms
are just over his head and his the
shoulder looks gnarly and then this was
the most Florida thing that happened the
entire time I was there I'm standing
next to this older dude and we're just
watching cuz I like watching that weird
[__] we're just watching and the guy
standing next to me
goes I think he's going to need another
shoulder
[Laughter]
surgery I said you
think and he goes no I know I'm his
doctor I did that
surgery
oh Florida
w